the realm of optics is advancing so
rapidly now that at MIT scientists were
able to create a super camera that has
one trillion frames per second now you
may say to yourself so what well think
of a light beam a light beam in a
billionth of a second travels about a
foot now when you look at yourself in a
mirror in the morning you say to
yourself well that's me actually that's
not you at all
you're looking at an image that is you a
billionth of a second ago because that's
the time it takes for light to go from
your face to the mirror back to your
eyes same thing for the moon when you
look at the moon
you're not really looking at the moon as
it is at all you're looking at the moon
as it was about a second ago well here's
a new camera
that can take a trillion frames per
second and actually capture these
processes that are beyond human
comprehension we forget the fact that
the human brain in our senses have a
timescale associated with it chemical
reactions in the brain chemical
reactions in the eye in our senses take
place at a very definite speed the speed
of chemical reactions so we have a
normal time frame our body measures time
in fractions of a second to a second two
minutes that's a normal frame of
reference of the human body but there's
a whole universe out there where events
take place on a scale of billions of a
second and another timescale where
events take place over a timescale of
billions of years and the sad thing is
that we humans our human brain is
unaccustomed to dealing with these two
extreme universes that we never see for
example evolution why is it that so many
people don't believe in evolution
because they can't see it happening with
their own eyes and now we're taking a
look at another time scale a scale of
billions of a second when perhaps in the
future we may be able to photograph
chemical reactions as they take place
this could open up a whole new realm of
science the science that takes place on
a scale
nanoseconds for example take a look at
photosynthesis photosynthesis is a
rather mysterious process believe it or
not we physicists still have not worked
out the complete quantum mechanics of
photosynthesis which mother nature
figured out billions of years ago
and part of the problem is these
chemical processes take place on a nano
scale that is way outside our ability to
photograph and that's why new cameras
like this could open up a gateway really
open up the floodgates to a new branch
of research